champion de la liberté de l'oat et
s'adresse d'abord à la prusse qui
détestent de l'enfance bien calé dans
son fauteuil
andré pruvost 80,2 on goûte à la
féliciter la lecture auditive et pour
cet homme atteint de cécité un moment de
plénitude 30 ans qu'ils empruntent des
enregistrements à la bibliothèque sonore
ça m'apporte de la distraction parce que
je lis un petit peu tout j'ai lu guéret
père lâche en train de lire la guerre
dans la grande armée l'a récemment je
viens de lire un autre livre qui est de
circonstance c'est j'écoute sur ton
visage
c'est le livre d'un monsieur dont la
femme était leimer comme la mienne
l'association des donneurs de voix de
châteauroux et de l'indre assez petit
mas laborieuse comme lucienne la doyenne
40 ans qu'elle est bénévole dans des
associations
j'étais dans les associations pour moi
pour que je joue pas tant pour les
autres moi je me disais je met en
contact des autres et ça vous rapporte
beaucoup plus que vous donnez un
formidable lui c'est la voix des
donneurs de voix donne à plus de trente
ans de bons et loyaux services
un palmarès éloquent j'ai enregistré 435
mire pour autour de 3200 km soit c'est
pas un exploit c'est parce que j'avais
l'impression de rendre un peu service
quoi alors plus j'enregistrais plus plus
je ne touchais 2
de gens qui avaient besoin de lire et
qui ne pouvaient pas fuit le ton des
cassettes voici venue l'heure du
numérique est décédé 16 heures
d'enregistrement pour alice au pays des
merveilles
destiné aux enfants souffrant de
troubles de l'apprentissage
[Musique]
le rythme relativement lent sans l'être
trop certains enfants vont pouvoir lire
et écouter en même temps
pour d'autres ce sera trop fatigant ils
ne vont avoir qu'une écoute donc il faut
que les coûts restent quand même
suffisamment dynamique pour que ne se
lasse pas mais pas trop rapide pour ceux
qui vont essayer de lire en même temps
l'association a urgemment besoin de
bénévoles
le rôle des bénévoles est très important
dans la mesure où il faut recevoir les
colis qui rend faire le tri ranger vérif
bien vérifier est renvoyé aux auditeurs
de nos livres des nouveaux livres à
écouter besoin de bénévoles certes mais
n'est dans sont aussi bienvenus